hello my name is scott ellis and i'm a
product manager on google cloud
and today we're going to talk about
managing sensitive data in hybrid
environments
what we're going to cover today is a
quick overview of our cloud data loss
prevention
or dlp platform and then we're going to
go and see how we can use dlp in hybrid
environments
and after that we're going to show a
demo of this by
by using dlp to inspect data in a mysql
database
that's running in a virtual machine and
then we're going to migrate some of that
data
into bigquery and use dlp again to do
data masking or data redaction let's get
started
so first an overview of our data loss
prevention platform
um first we feel that protecting
sensitive data really begins with
knowing where that data exists
and so one of the core features of our
platform
is discovery and classification and our
data last prevention platform again is a
fully managed service that helps you
discover classify and protect your most
sensitive data
and we do this again through discovery
classification
as well as a set of tools called
de-identification which is a way to
transform or mask sensitive data and
this platform is built to work on
structured data
unstructured data as well as workloads
that might be in real time
or kind of in at rest or in batch
um to cover this a little more detail
when we talk about discovery and
classification of sensitive data
what we mean is being able to look at
data and identify
different elements inside that data that
might be sensitive an example of that
could be
things like personally identifiable
information or pii
this would be things like names dates of
birth
credit card numbers and a variety of
different things
and we have different types out of the
box that we support
that are both kind of global as well as
country specific identifiers
we also have some special categories
like credentials and secrets
that help look for things like passwords
or off tokens
whether it be on our cloud or other
clouds and these are things that might
not identify a person
but are sensitive and might give a kind
of a credential or access
to privileged access to resources you
can also customize all of this
either by defining your own own info
type detectors
or by using detection rules to change
how our detectors work or to tune them
for your needs
that second set of capabilities again we
call de-identification it's often
referred to
as things like data masking or
tokenization and this is where we go in
and actually manipulate
the data to try to de-risk it or
obfuscate it somehow
and if you can see in this kind of
before and after animation what we're
doing is we're applying those techniques
to different columns in this table in
the first three columns we are applying
a technique
that basically transforms the entire
column and then in that fourth column
the comments field
we're actually using a combination of
our inspection and our masking
to look for data inside of the cell
and only redact that item so you see in
that first row
we actually find an email address but
instead of removing the entire
cell or the entire comment we just
remove the email address and leave the
rest intact
so that's an example sort of how we
combine our inspection
and our de-identification to work on
unstructured data or semi-structured
data
and you know where this is a may uh be
applicable or where you might use this
um one example is to help
prevent exposure of raw secrets or
sensitive data
um so imagine again you had let's say uh
your public website your company website
and all of those public assets were
hosted in a cloud storage bucket
and these are assets that power your
website that are generally
available to anyone when they're viewing
your website but what happens if
somebody uploads something
into that bucket or into that folder
that is uh
shouldn't be there maybe it's sensitive
so running something like an inspection
scan of that bucket
we could identify for example here if
somebody uploaded a gcp credential into
that bucket
which again you would not want to expose
that publicly as i could give privileged
access to some of your resources
another example would be to kind of
unblock workloads maybe it's a machine
learning or artificial intelligence
workload
or some sort of a cloud migration
workload and here we would look at
moving data into those different
environments and applying that
de-identification to obscure or mask the
data
but still allow that analysis or that
machine learning to happen
another use case would be really just to
understand and classify
data across your entire enterprise and
our cloud platform has
an api a rest or a grpc api that enables
you to call it from virtually anywhere
and that's what we're going to focus on
in the next section is how we can use
this in in
hybrid environments that may be on or
off cloud or on or off
google cloud and let's get into that
so what do we actually mean by hybrid
environments um
well really we're thinking of again
taking those core capabilities around
inspection
classification and masking and
applying it on data that might be in
other clouds might be on premise
could be in non-native storage systems
this could be like a database that
you're running inside of a virtual
machine
maybe it's running inside of an
application like a web or a mobile app
or it could of course be running on
google cloud
so a few examples of that maybe you want
to inspect data that's running in
something like
aws says rds system um or maybe it's a
mysql database running inside of a
virtual machine
or again a database that's running on
premise we're actually going to show a
demo of this
later looking at mysql running in a
virtual machine
maybe you want to inspect and tokenize
data as you're migrating that data from
on-prem
into cloud or between environments like
production development and analytics
another example could be inspecting and
redacting transactions from a
web or mobile application before you
store that data at rest
so to do this we're going to talk about
two of our methods these are two methods
on our cloud dlp platform one called
content methods and one called hybrid
methods
now hybrid methods are a newer method
that we've released recently
um but let's go over both of these
methods so first content methods
you'll notice actually that these are
pretty similar as far as the kind of
data sources that they
apply to this could be data running on
any cloud on-premise and virtually any
data source
but with content methods it's what we
call a synchronous
um like request and response these are
methods where you
make a request you send data in that
request and you get a response back
in that request and that response is
sort of the answer it's the
classification or the mass data these
methods are stateless
and they allow both inspection and
de-identification capabilities
now a new hybrid methods um are similar
but a little bit different what they do
is they actually take your data they
allow you to sort of do a fire and
forget where you can send this data in
for inspection
but then move on you don't have to wait
for the response or process the response
and here dlp will aggregate that data
and put it put it together and aggregate
it so that you can store that data or
analyze it for example in something like
bigquery or make reports in data studio
or publish other types of alerts and for
now this is only for inspection
and that's what we're going to talk a
little bit later and demo this later as
well
how we can take information send it
through these hybrid methods
and then produce an audit report using
bigquery and data studio but again these
are kind of the two methods you would
use to handle data
in in hybrid environments
and here's an example of what that kind
of audit report might look like
so again imagine you're scanning data
across several different assets and you
want to
collect all of this in one place analyze
it using bigquery
or visualize it in some sort of a audit
report like we're showing here
using something like data studio in this
example we're showing
several different things that we've
inspected and as you see we're getting
results
about what kind of database we looked at
what tables and columns and dlp findings
we have there
now another aspect to this is what we
call region regionalization
and with dlp you also have regional
endpoints and this means that you can
actually specify
where your data is being processed so
for example let's say you want to
inspect data
from on premise but you want to make
sure that the inspection part that's
running
on our platform is limited to a
particular location
maybe you want all your data to stay in
australia or in europe or in the us
you can specify a regional endpoint
which means that your data will be
processed in that region
and it gives you the control whether
you're doing it for data residency
purposes
or uh you're planning out sort of an
availability
or um kind of a performance or latency
requirement
you can pick those regional endpoints if
you need to
great now let's go in and kind of go a
little bit deeper on what these hybrid
methods look like
so when we use the new hybrid method
um what we do is we create a hybrid job
and this job it really is an active
listener that's going to be listening
for requests
and then aggregating all those findings
uh for you so that you can come back
later and see the results
and when we define this request we're
going to basically create a job and
instead of specifying a storage location
like cloud storage or bigquery
we would pick a storage location of
hybrid we would then provide additional
metadata
for that job now this metadata is
important because that's the information
that we're going to use to aggregate
everything together
you can specify some of that in the
actual job
or in each request
and let's go into a little bit more
detail of what a request might look like
so here is an actual code sample where
we're showing
what a hybrid inspection request would
look like
on the right side we're actually this is
a code sample in java
and what we're showing here at the top
is there's some content that we want to
inspect
in this case we're going to be
inspecting tabular data so we provided
headers and rows of that data then we
have our hybrid
our actual hybrid request in this case
that's where we're supplying all of
those details
uh all that metadata that we want to
aggregate around so here's where we
would pass it things like
a mysql database type or a version
or maybe a database name or table name
because we want to
add those kind of things to our report
later on
and then we send the request and in this
example again this is just showing the
snippet that will basically provide
all that information and send that
request in and then on the server side
dlp will inspect that data
aggregate it together and allow you to
then go in and analyze that information
uh using something like bigquery or data
studio
great now that we've shown you kind of
what a request looks like let's move
into an actual demo of this and what
we're going to show in this demo
is we're going to we're going to scan
data that's running in a mysql database
that is running on a virtual machine um
we're going to inspect that data
and then we're going to migrate one of
those tables over to bigquery
using dlp again to do masking so we
basically can kind of protect that data
as we're migrating it from this virtual
machine
into a managed service like bigquery
great let's get started on the demo
we're going to show a demo in two parts
in part one we're going to inspect data
from a mysql database that's running in
a virtual machine
and to do this we're going to use a
custom script that's going to read this
information
send it into our cloud data loss
prevention platform using the hybrid
inspection method
which is going to then write data into
bigquery and we're going to visualize
that in data studio
the second part we're going to migrate a
table
from that mysql database using cloud dlp
and data flow to tokenize that data
as we move it into a bigquery and
migrate it from mysql into bigquery
let's get started
great the first thing we're going to do
is create a new hybrid job
to do that i've navigated to security
and then data loss prevention in the
cloud console
and now i'm going to click on create and
then job
provided name for the job and then pick
a storage location of hybrid
now hybrid again means that it's going
to create an active listener
it's going to be listening for request
streams each of those request streams
will include the content
that we want to inspect as well as any
labels that act as metadata
so again these labels could define the
type of data that we're scanning
maybe a database in our demo will be a
mysql database
the database name and the table name now
we can put required labels here which
means every request is required
to have that label filled out as well as
optional labels
that we can apply at the job level but
they can be overridden
by each request
now the rest of this job configuration
is similar to other job types
i define the types of things that i want
to look for either by using a template
or by putting the configuration as i
have here
in the job and then when i'm done i
simply click create
great now that we have our job
we're ready to use it so uh
i switched environments here to a
project that is running our mysql vm
now in this case we've chosen to use
google's compute engine
to host the mysql instance and run the
script
but again this could be a vm running you
know
anywhere either clouds on premise and
again the script here that we're running
is connecting to the database using a
standard jdbc protocol
and so we're in the vm let's go ahead
and just see what kind of data we have
here
so what i'm doing here is i'm just
simply selecting a database called
company2
and then we are seeing the tables that
are in there looks like we've got a
handful of tables
and we're going to use dlp to inspect
these tables
now in the job we've configured it to
write say
write and save findings into bigquery
and so that allows us to then go do
analysis either in bigquery using sql
or in a tool like data studio where we
can visualize things
all right let's get started so we're
going to run a script here
now this script again is just going to
look at the the information
stream a sample in this case we've set
the limit to 10 000 rows
per table it's going to stream a sample
of that data dlp is going to inspect it
and then generate those findings
also note here that um even though we
have a username and a password in this
command line
that's not the actual database password
we are using our secret manager
which is a tool that allows you to
protect enterprise and production
secrets
in instances like this
so as you see we're running this script
here and you see that with a little note
here retrieving password from cloud
secret manager
and we're running the script in just a
few seconds we've gone through all the
different tables
read a sample and done some inspection
here and again we
we name this next 2020 demo one so when
we go into our report
let's look for that data so i'm going to
switch over here
to data studio now this is a report
we've been using for a lot of test runs
so we already have data in here and now
we've run test runs on local instances
uh ones running in in compute engine uh
one's running in different systems from
other clouds here
as well as even running against systems
like bigquery which also have a jdbc
connector so again it's a very versatile
script
and again leveraging our hybrid methods
we're able to see all of this data from
several different runs
all collected in this audit report but
i'm going to go ahead and refresh the
data here
and let's see if our demo
data is available yet so again we sent
those sample data
into dlp it inspected it now we're just
kind of refreshing to see if that data
is available
okay so we see here we have next 2020
demo one
let's click there and see if we can see
any findings here it looks like we found
90
000 different things again sending 10
000 rows per table there could be
multiple findings per row so that's
probably where we got into the 90
000. great um so we see a couple
different tables here
and we're going to look at this first
one the cars table again
as we see here it looks like we were
running my sql
version here again we scanned database
company 2
it looks like we found something in the
cars table we found a vin number and an
email address so again this is just a
quick way to show
the power of hybrid so what we did is we
ran the script
streamed in a sample of data and within
a few seconds we scanned all the tables
and a few seconds later that data was
inspected by dlp
and made available through bigquery and
data studio for reporting
now again for part two we're going to
actually take some of that data from
that database and migrate it into
bigquery
and use cloud dlp to tokenize that data
along the way
so if you remember we found we're going
to use this cars table here and if you
remember we found
sensitive data vin number and email
address
so what we're going to do is we're
actually going to migrate that data
so we're going to export it from my sql
and we're going to use
a pipeline that is powered by uh data
flow
in order to process that data and ingest
it into bigquery
now one of the first things that we're
going to do is define exactly what we
want to de-identify
so to do that we're going to navigate
back over to
our security and data loss prevention
in the cloud console and we're going to
create a de-identification template
so i click here on create go to template
we're going to do a de-identification
template now d-identification is a term
that's really to a collection of
techniques to transform this data
in this case we're going to do a record
transformation
and let's just call this test vid
2. continue here now when we're doing a
record transformation what that means is
that we're going to apply
transformations
on an entire column now we can leverage
our info type inspection as well that's
the thing that we use to find that vin
number and find that email
but in this case we've already done that
remember we had a column called
then and email that had sensitive data
in it
so we're just going to create a simple
template here
for the field then in email we're going
to do
what's called a primitive transformation
so we're not going to
we're not going to rely on it finding
the email in the vin because we already
know that column has it
and we're going to simply go in and
we're going to do a
deterministic token or pseudonymization
what that's going to do is convert the
vin
and the email into a token that keeps
deterministic and referential integrity
i'm going to cancel this because i've
already created that template that we're
going to use
which is listed here as next 2020 cars
did one
now i'm going to navigate over to
dataflow
now in dataflow we've actually already
got this pipeline running but just to
show you how we got there
we create we'll click on create job from
template we name our job this will be
test job
one and we actually pick an existing
template here called
masking tokenization from cloud dlp to
bigquery
this is going to ask us for a few
parameters again it wants to know the
path that we're going to land
or drop our csv files into where do we
want to ingest them in bigquery
and again that reference to that
de-identification template that we just
created
so again filling this out clicking run
job that's how we get this pipeline
started
let's actually go and show this pipeline
in action
so i've got this pipeline running here
and i've also got the bucket that i'm
using to ingest this data
now um we already downloaded or pulled
that data out of my sql
and so just for the purpose of this demo
what i'm going to do is go ahead and
upload
that file great so we just uploaded a
very small sample of this file again
we're trying to show sort of that
end-to-end workflow here
as we see here it's pulling for the
input file
it looks like we processed some files
here we've run some tokenization
i'm going to go over to bigquery here
let's just refresh this so we can pull
up that data set that we're writing the
results to
and let's see if it's there yet okay
great
so you see here we have a cars table
that's just been created
let's just go look at a preview here and
as you can see the email address
and the vin number have both been
obfuscated and basically de-identified
so that we're protecting that
information what this means is someone
can now analyze this data
that we've extracted and moved over from
that mysql database
without revealing the email address but
they can still do joins they can still
do aggregates
because we've chosen to use a
deterministic
tokenization method that preserves that
integrity so again the same email
gets the same token same vin number gets
the same
token but we're not revealing the
underlying sensitive data
and this concludes the second part of
our demo where we wanted to show sort of
a hybrid migration
taking data from a hybrid system in this
case mysql
and migrating that into cloud in this
case into bigquery
using cloud dlp to protect that data
through tokenization and
de-identification
thanks again for your time great well i
hope that demo showed you some of the
power of cloud dlp
and how you can use that in hybrid
environments for more details
check out the link below where you can
learn about our data loss prevention
platform
as well as see more examples and use
cases for how to apply dlp
both on cloud and off cloud in these
hybrid environments
thank you again